Good morning, Hank; it's Wednesday. Who am
I kidding? You're not watching this; you're
in Haiti!
Hank, I'm really grateful to you for being
the noble brother who goes out there on the
front lines to decrease WorldSuck because
that means that I can stay in my basement.
Why am I still talking to him? He's not watching!
We are free from the tyranny of Hank!
Okay, nerdfighters. This morning I went to
Your Pants and asked for some questions and
now... here are some answers!
"After reading 'Looking for Alaska,' I wonder
if you've thought about what you want your
last words to be before you die."
Not at all. To paraphrase the great John Barrymore,
"dying is the last thing I would ever do."
"Did you have any nicknames as a teenager?"
Yeah, one time I said that Christian Slater
never made a bad more and, thereafter, a lot
of my friends called me "Kuffs."
"Dandy lions or dandelions?"
Oh, dandy lions for sure. Do you know what
happens if you wish on a dandy lion?
He eats you.
By the way, "The Dandy Lions"... really good
band name.
"It's tax time again. Any fishing boat proceeds
this year?"
No. Stupid fishing boats always refusing to
give me proceeds.
"When's your new book coming out?"
In almost exactly one year.
"What's it about?"
Uh, it's about these two teenage cancer survivors
who are both obsessed with this reclusive
novelist, but it's also about a bunch of other
things like Swedish hip-hop and, you know,
the meaning of life and stuff.
"Is it really narrated by a girl?"
Yes! Hazel!
"What's the title?"
I don't know! I change it, like, every day
and they all suck!
Do you have any good titles? If you have any
good titles, please leave them in comments!
"What is the biggest obstacle, in your opinion,
to getting started as a professional writer?"
Um, essentially, the world contains a lot
of books and not that many people who are
willing to pay to read them.
"Can you say the alphabet backwards?"
Z, Y, X, W... no.
"Are you friends with Libba Bray? Have you
read any of her books?"
Yes, I'm friends with Libba Bray, and I've
read all of her books, including "Beauty Queens,"
which isn't even out yet.
Did you know that Libba Bray just broke both
of her elbows? I realize that sounds like
a euphemism for being pregnant with twins
or something, but seriously, Libba Bray just
broke both of her elbows.
And I'm not even that surprised about it,
to be honest. Like, if you told me, "John,
one of your friends just broke both of her
elbows," I would be, like, "I bet it was Libba!"
You never here about people like Sarah Dessen
breaking both of their elbows. It just doesn't
happen. Poor Libba. Anyway, her new book is
amazing; you should preorder it — link in
the dooblydoo. I didn't end up writing a desert
island novel because, you know, after Libba's,
I don't have to.
"Will you ever walk alone?"
No!
And if I didn't know this was a Liverpool
scarf, I might think I was dressing up as
Waldo for Christmas.
[to self] You don't dress up for Christmas,
Green. Get your head outta your ass.
"Hey, is your phone number secretly inserted
into 'Looking for Alaska'?"
Yeah... that used to be my phone number. I
mean, when I wrote "Looking for Alaska," I
didn't think more than about nine people would
read it, you know, so yes, I did put my phone
number in it.
I have a message for the person who has that
phone number now: Sorry.
"Favorite old-school video game?"
Pong, because I like video games that are
like life and Pong just keeps getting harder
until you die.
"Have you ever been arrested?"
No.
"Coffee or tea?"
Coffee. I'm hiding from the British people.
"If you could, would you?"
Probably not. Let's face it: I'm not the kinda
guy who does.
Hank, thank you for going to Haiti. We look
forward to the most amazing Thoughts from
Places videos ever, and I will see you on
Friday when I upload the video that you already
made.
But I will really see you on... I'm so bad
at this... Wednesday? It seems so far away.